el reporte pide que haya un impuesto
progresivo a la riqueza extrema algo que
podría llevar a sacar a dos mil millones
de personas de la pobreza es esto
posible Y por qué no actúan los estados
o las autoridades
Sandra creo que tiene su micrófono
apagado no le estamos escuchando
la invitación y estaba diciéndote que si
es posible
cerrar estas brechas de desigualdad que
presenta el informe grabando justamente
el impuesto a los más a Los más
millonarios es una decisión política la
desigualdad es una decisión política y
lo que estamos citando desde oxfam es
invitando a los gobiernos A que pongan
esta clase de de impuestos por un lado
que hayan unos impuestos solidarios de
carácter temporal de hecho ya ha habido
experiencias exitosas como la que hubo
en Argentina durante la pandemia del
cobi 19 que logró generar unos ingresos
adicionales para el Estado para cubrir
la emergencia sanitaria y lo que estamos
pidiendo de fondo Más allá de las
emergencias es incrementar de manera
sistemática todos los tipos de impuestos
sobre la renta a este uno por ciento más
rico
que es como bien lo lo señalabas
están creciendo a una manera desaforada
en los últimos dos años en medio de
justo lo que veíamos ahora de lo que
está pasando en Ucrania más la pandemia
del Coby 19 y mientras el grueso de la
población se sumerge en la pobreza y en
la carencia el uno por ciento de la
población está recibiendo ganancias que
ni en sus mejores proyecciones habían
previsto tener hace diez años bueno es
que justamente una de las cosas que
llaman la atención es que esta es la
mayor Bonanza para los millonarios de la
última década justo en plena pandemia
usted a que se lo atribuye
al flujo de recursos que se inyectaron
desde el sector público
justamente para tratar de sostener y
revitalizar la
la economía que se vio tan afectada por
las medidas de cuarentena y que
paralizaron la economía un flujo
bastante amplio
de los recursos públicos para lograr
solventar la situación pero ya es el
momento de tomar medidas y de generar
estos impuestos porque en la actualidad
los más ricos ese uno por ciento son los
que menos impuestos pagan Y eso está
sustentado en la teoría de que al
rebajarle los impuestos a Los más
millonarios y a las empresas se genera
empleo y se genera riqueza por goteo
para la población pero ya está
demostrado que no es así esto es un mito
durante muchos años muchas reformas en
los países más pobres reformas
tributarias lo que hicieron fue
generarle beneficios económicos a las
empresas para que generaran empleo para
que generaran riqueza y por goteo se
lograra el beneficio Pero eso no se
logró y es el momento de volver a
modelos cansio exitosos en otros
momentos de la historia hablamos de la
posguerra después de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial o de las grandes crisis
económicas donde los estados hicieron
una carga impositiva mucho más fuerte a
quienes más dinero tienen Y eso generó
en realidad mejores condiciones de
desarrollo lo que queremos es acento
justamente cerrar esa brecha si se
pusiera este impuesto de un cinco por
ciento a Los más millonarios se lograría
recoger el dinero suficiente para hacer
un plan que nos llevara a diez años a la
erradicación del hambre en el planeta
bueno Y es que por otro lado los
salarios reales han perdido casi un 10%
de su valor entre el 2020 y el año 2022
y millones de personas 32,1% de la
población viven en pobreza 82 millones
de ellos ya están en situación de
pobreza extrema es culpa de los que más
acaparan la riqueza
es culpa de un sistema económico que
favorece a los que más acaparon la
riqueza por eso estamos diciendo es una
decisión política necesitamos que los
gobiernos tomen la decisión de grabar
estas riquezas de grabar la renta el
patrimonio y las ganancias que tienen
estas empresas lo que generaría lo que
permitiría que el estado logre su
función Estatal que es la redistribución
de la riqueza Quienes más tienen más
deben aportar el sistema y en este
momento no está haciendo así el informe
da Unión unos ejemplos muy claros de
cómo el hombre más rico del planeta paga
en efectivo realmente un 3% de impuestos
mientras que una vendado una vendedora
comerciante en uganda que recibe un
ingreso medio muy bajo tiene que pagar
un cuarenta por ciento de sus de lo que
ya logré vender Entonces realmente es
inequitativo el sistema y necesitamos
que los gobiernos los estados cumplen su
función Quienes más ganan Quienes más
tienen deben aportar más y el estado
debe redistribuir otro problema que
tenemos es que las personas pagan los
impuestos y buena parte de esos
impuestos se van para pagar la deuda no
para invertir en sea seguridad social en
la alimentación la salud y la educación
que es para donde deberían ir los
recursos para generar bienestar y
desarrollo